The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN SHUN: So welcome to
the second lecture of 6.172,
performance engineering
of software systems.
Today, we're going to be
talking about Bentley rules
for optimizing work.
All right, so work, does
anyone know what work means?
You're all at MIT,
so you should know.
So in terms of
computer programming,
there's actually a formal
definition of work.
The work of a program
on a particular input
is defined to be the sum total
of all the operations executed
by the program.
So it's basically
a gross measure
of how much stuff the
program needs to do.
And the idea of
optimizing work is
to reduce the amount of
stuff that the program needs
to do in order to improve the
running time of your program,
improve its performance.
So algorithm design can
produce dramatic reductions
in the work of a program.
For example, if you want to
sort an array of elements,
you can use a nlogn
time QuickSort.
Or you can use an n squared
time sort, like insertion sort.
So you've probably
seen this before
in your algorithm courses.
And for large
enough values of n,
a nlogn time sort
is going to be much
faster than a n squared sort.
So today, I'm not going to be
talking about algorithm design.
You'll see more of this in
other courses here at MIT.
And we'll also talk a little
bit about algorithm design
later on in this semester.
We will be talking about many
other cool tricks for reducing
the work of a program.
But I do want to point
out, that reducing
the work of our program
doesn't automatically translate
to a reduction in running time.
And this is because
of the complex nature
of computer hardware.
So there's a lot of things
going on that aren't captured
by this definition of work.
There's instruction level
parallelism, caching,
vectorization, speculation and
branch prediction, and so on.
And we'll learn about
some of these things
throughout this semester.
But reducing the
work of our program
does serve as a good
heuristic for reducing
the overall running time
of a program, at least
to a first order.
So today, we'll be
learning about many ways
to reduce the work
of your program.
So rules we'll be
looking at, we call
them Bentley optimization rules,
in honor of John Lewis Bentley.
So John Lewis Bentley wrote
a nice little book back
in 1982 called Writing
Efficient Programs.
And inside this book there
are various techniques
for reducing the work
of a computer program.
So if you haven't seen this
book before, it's very good.
So I highly encourage
you to read it.
Many of the original
rules in Bentley's book
had to deal with the vagaries
of computer architecture
three and a half decades ago.
So today, we've
created a new set
of Bentley rules just dealing
with the work of a program.
We'll be talking about
architecture-specific
optimizations later
on in the semester.
But today, we won't
be talking about this.
One cool fact is that John
Lewis Bentley is actually
my academic great grandfather.
So John Bentley was one
of Charles Leiseron's
academic advisors.
Charles Leiserson was Guy
Blelloch's academic advisor.
And Guy Blelloch, who's a
professor at Carnegie Mellon,
was my advisor when I was
a graduate student at CMU.
So it's a nice little fact.
And I had the honor of meeting
John Bentley a couple of years
ago at a conference.
And he told me that he was my
academic great grandfather.
[LAUGHING]
Yeah, and Charles is my
academic grandfather.
And all of Charles's students
are my academic aunts
and uncles--
[LAUGHING]
--including your T.A. Helen.
OK, so here's a list of
all the work optimizations
that we'll be looking at today.
So they're grouped into four
categories, data structures,
loops, and functions.
So there's a list of 22
rules on this slide today.
In fact, we'll actually be able
to look at all of them today.
So today's lecture is
going to be structured
as a series of many lectures.
And I'm going to be spending
one to three slides on each one
of these optimizations.
All right, so let's
start with optimizations
for data structures.
So first optimization
is packing and encoding
your data structure.
And the idea of packing is to
store more than one data value
in a machine word.
And the related
idea of encoding is
to convert data values
into a representation that
requires fewer bits.
So does anyone know why
this could possibly reduce
the running time of a program?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Need less
memory fetches.
JULIAN SHUN: Right,
so good answer.
The answer was, it might
need less memory fetches.
And it turns out
that that's correct,
because computer program
spends a lot of time moving
stuff around in memory.
And if you reduce
the number of things
that you have to move
around in memory,
then that's a good heuristic
for reducing the running
time of your program.
So let's look at an example.
Let's say we wanted
to encode dates.
So let's say we wanted to code
this string, September 11,
2018.
You can store this
using 18 bytes.
So you can use one byte
per character here.
And this would require
more than two double words,
because each double word
is eight bytes or 64 bits.
And you have 18 bytes.
You need more than
two double words.
And you have to move
around these words
every time you want to
manipulate the date.
But turns out that
you can actually
do better than using 18 bytes.
So let's assume that we
only want to store years
between 4096 BCE and 4096 CE.
So there are about
365.25 times 8,192 dates
in this range, which is
three million approximately.
And you can use log base
two of three million bits
to represent all the
dates within this range.
So the notation lg here
means log base of two.
That's going to be the notation
I'll be using in this class.
And L-O-G will mean log base 10.
So we take the ceiling of log
base two or three million,
and that gives us 22 bits.
So a good way to remember
how to compute the log
base two of something, you
can remember that the log base
two of one million is 20,
log base two of 1,000 is 10.
And then you can factor this
out and then add in log base
two of three, rounded
up, which is two.
So that gives you 22 bits.
And that easily fits
within one 32-bit words.
Now, you only need one word
instead of three words,
as you did in the
original representation.
But with this modified
representation,
now determining the month
of a particular date
will take more work, because
now you're not explicitly
storing the month in
your representation.
Whereas, with the
string representation,
you are explicitly storing it
at the beginning of the string.
So this does take more work,
but it requires less space.
So any questions so far?
OK, so it turns out
that there's another way
to store this, which
also makes it easy
for you to fetch the
month, the year, or the day
for a particular date.
So here, we're going to use
the bit fields facilities in C.
So we're going to create a
struct called date underscore t
with three fields, the year,
the month, and the date.
And the integer
after the semicolon
specifies how many
bits I want to assign
to this particular
field in the struct.
So this says, I need
13 bits for the year,
four bits for the month,
and five bits for the day.
So the 13 bits for
the year is, because I
have 8,192 possible years.
So I need 13 bits to store that.
For the month, I have
12 possible months.
So I need log base two of 12
rounded up, which is four.
And then finally,
for the day, I need
log base two of 31
rounded up, which is five.
So in total, this
still takes 22 bits.
But now the individual
fields can now
be accessed much more
quickly, than if we had just
encoded the three million dates
using sequential integers,
because now you can just extract
a month just by saying whatever
you named your struct.
You can just say that
struct dot month.
And that give you the month.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does C actually
store it like that,
because I know C++
it makes it finalize.
So then you end up
taking more space.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so this will actually
pad the struct a little
bit at the end, yeah.
So you actually do require a
little bit more than 22 bits.
That's a good question.
But this representation is
much more easy to access,
than if you just had
encoded the integers
as sequential integers.
Another point is that sometimes
unpacking and decoding
are the optimization,
because sometimes it
takes a lot of work to encode
the values and to extract them.
So sometimes you want to
actually unpack the values
so that they take more space,
but they're faster to access.
So it depends on your
particular application.
You might want to do
one thing or the other.
And the way to figure this out
is just to experiment with it.
OK, so any other questions?
All right, so the
second optimization
is data structure augmentation.
And the idea here is to add
information to a data structure
to make common
operations do less work,
so that they're faster.
And let's look at an example.
Let's say we had two
singly linked list
and we wanted to
append them together.
And let's say we only stored
the head pointer to the list,
and then each
element in the list
has a pointer to the
next element in the list.
Now, if you want to spend
one list to another list,
well, that's going to require
you walking down the first list
to find the last
element, so that you
can change the pointer
of the last element
to point to the beginning
of the next list.
And this might be very slow if
the first list is very long.
So does anyone see a way to
augment this data structure so
that appending two lists can
be done much more efficiently?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Store a pointer
to the last value.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so the answer is
to store a pointer
to the last value.
And we call that
the tail pointer.
So now we have two pointers,
both the head and the tail.
The head points to the
beginning of the list.
The tail points to
the end of the list.
And now you can just append
two lists in constant time,
because you can access the
last element in the list
by following the tail pointer.
And then now you just
change the successor pointer
of the last element to point
to the head of the second list.
And then now you also
have to update the tail
to point to the end
of the second list.
OK, so that's the idea of
data structure augmentation.
We added a little bit
of extra information
to the data structure,
such that now appending
two lists is much more efficient
than in the original method,
where we only had
a head pointer.
Questions?
OK, so the next optimization
is precomputation.
The idea of precomputation is
to perform some calculations
in advance so as to avoid
doing these computations
at mission-critical times, to
avoid doing them at runtime.
So let's say we had
a program that needed
to use binomial coefficients.
And here's a definition
of a binomial coefficient.
So it's basically
the choose function.
So you want to count
the number of ways
that you can choose k things
from a set of n things.
And the formula
for computing this
is, n factorial divided by the
product of k factorial and n
minus k factorial.
Computing this choose
function can actually
be quite expensive,
because you have
to do a lot of multiplications
to compute the factorial,
even if the final
result is not that big,
because you have to compute one
term in the numerator and then
two factorial terms
in the denominator.
And then you also might run
into integer overflow issues,
because n factorial
grows very fast.
It grows super exponentially.
It grows like n to the n,
which is even faster than two
to the n, which is exponential.
So doing this
computation, you have
to be very careful with
integer overflow issues.
So one idea to speed
up a program that
uses these binomials
coefficients
is to precompute a
table of coefficients
when you initialize
the program, and then
just perform table lookup
on this precomputed table
at runtime when you need
the binomial coefficient.
So does anyone know
what the table that
stores binomial
coefficients is called?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yea,
Pascal's triangles, good.
So here is what Pascal's
triangle looks like.
So on the vertical axis, we
have different values of n.
And then on the horizontal axis,
we have different values of k.
And then to get
and choose k, you
just go to the nth
row in the case column
and look up that entry.
Pascal's triangle
has a nice property,
that for every element,
it can be computed
as a sum of the element
directly above it and above it
and to the left of it.
So here, 56 is the
sum of 35 and 21.
And this gives us a
nice formula to compute
the binomial coefficients.
So we first check if n is less
than k in this choose function.
If n is less than
k, then we just
return zero,
because we're trying
to choose more things
than there are in a set.
If n is equal to
zero, then we just
return one, because here k
must also be equal to zero,
since we had the condition
n less than k above.
And there's one way
to choose zero things
from a set of zero things.
And then if k is
equal to zero, we also
return one, because
there's only one way
to choose zero things from a
set of any number of things.
You just don't pick anything.
And then finally, we recursively
call this choose function.
So we call choose of n
minus one k minus one.
This is essentially the entry
above and diagonal to this.
And then we add in choose
of n minus one k, which
is the entry directly above it.
So this is a recursive function
for generating this Pascal's
triangle.
But notice that we're actually
still not doing precomputation,
because every time we
call this choose function,
we're making two
recursive calls.
And this can still
be pretty expensive.
So how can we actually
precompute this table?
So here's some C code for
precomputing Pascal's triangle.
And let's say we only
wanted coefficients up
to choose sides of 100.
So we initialize
matrix of 100 by 100.
And then we call this
an init choose function.
So first it goes from n
equal zero, all the way up
to choose size minus one.
And then it says, choose
n of zero to be one.
It also sets choose
of n, n to be one.
So the first line
is, because there's
only one way to
choose zero things
from any number of things.
And the second line is,
because there's only one way
to choose n things
from n things, which
is just to pick all of them.
And then now we
have a second loop,
which goes from n equals
one, all the way up to choose
size minus one.
Then first we set
choose of zero n
to be zero, because here n is--
or k is greater than n.
So there's no way to
pick more elements
from a set of things that is
less than the number of things
you want to pick.
And then now you loop from k
equals one, all the way up to n
minus one.
And then your apply
this recursive formula.
So choose of n, k is
equal to choose of n minus
one, k minus one plus
choose of n minus one k.
And then you also set
choose of k, n to be zero.
So this is basically all of
the entries above the diagonal
here, where k is greater than n.
And then now inside
the program whenever
we need a binomial coefficient
that's less than 100,
we can just do table
lookup into this table.
And we just index and
then just choose array.
So does this make sense?
Any questions?
It's pretty easy so far, right?
So one thing to note
is, that we're still
computing this table
at runtime, because we
have to initialize
this table at runtime.
And if we want to run
our program many times,
then we have to initialize
this table many times.
So is there a way to only
initialize this table once,
even though we might want to
run the program many times?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Put in
the source code.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so good,
so put it in the source code.
And so we're going to do
compile-time initialization.
And if you put the table
in the source code,
then the compiler
will compile this code
and generate the table
for you that compile time.
So now whenever you
run it, you don't
have to spend time
initializing the table.
So idea of compile-time
initialization
is to store the
values of constants
during compilation
and, therefore,
saving work at runtime.
So let's say we wanted
choose values up to 10.
This is the table, the
10 by 10 table storing
all of the binomial
coefficients up to 10.
So if you put this
in your source code,
now when you run
the program, you
can just index into this table
to get the appropriate constant
here.
But this table was
just a 10 by 10 table.
What if you wanted a
table of 1,000 by 1,000?
Does anyone actually want to
type this in, a table of 1,000
by 1,000?
So probably not.
So is there any way
to get around this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You could make
a program that uses it.
And the function will be
defined [INAUDIBLE] prints
out the zero [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so the answer is
to write a program that
writes your program for you.
And that's called
metaprogramming.
So here's a snippet
of code that will
generate this table for you.
So it's going to call
this init choose function
that we defined before.
And then now it's just
going to print out C code.
So it's going to print out
the declaration of this array
choose, followed
by a left bracket.
And then for each
row of the table,
we're going to print
another left bracket
and then print the value of
each entry in that row, followed
by a right bracket.
And we do that for every row.
So this will give
you the C code.
And then now you can just copy
and paste this and place it
into your source code.
This is a pretty cool
technique to get your computer
to do work for you.
And you're welcome to use this
technique in your homeworks
and projects if you'd need
to generate large tables
of constant values.
So this is a very good
technique to know.
So any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there a way to
write the output other programs
to a file, as oppose to
having to copy and paste
into the source code?
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so you can
pipe the output of this program
to a file.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So are there
compiler tools that can--
so we have three
processor tools.
Is there [INAUDIBLE]
processor can do that?
We compile the code, run
it, and then [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so I think you
can write macros to actually
generate this table.
And then the compiler
will run those macros
to generate this table for you.
Yeah, so you don't actually need
to copy and paste it yourself.
Yeah?
CHARLES: And you
know, you don't have
to write it in C. If it's
quicker to write with Python,
you'd be writing in Python,
just put it in the make file
for the system you're building.
So if it's in the
make file, says,
well, we're making
this thing, first
generate the file in
the table and now you
include that in whatever
you're compiling
or/and it's just one
more step in the process.
And for sure, it's
generally easier
to write these tables with the
scripting language like Python
than writing them in
C. On the other hand,
if you need experience writing
in C, practice writing in C.
JULIAN SHUN: Right,
so as Charles says,
you can write your metaprogram
using any language.
You don't have to write it in
C. You can write it in Python
if you're more
familiar with that.
And it's often easier to
write it using a scripting
language like Python.
OK, so let's look at
the next optimization.
So we're already
gone through a couple
of mini lectures already.
So congratulations to all
of you who are still here.
So the next
optimization is caching.
The idea of caching
is to store results
that have been
accessed recently,
so that you don't need
to compute them again
in the program.
So let's look at an example.
Let's say we wanted to
compute the hypotenuse
of a right triangle with
side lengths A and B.
So the formula for
computing this is, you
take the square root of A
times A plus B times B. OK, so
turns out that the square
root operator is actually
a relatively expensive, more
expensive than additions
and multiplications
on modern machines.
So you don't want to have
to call the square root
function if you don't have to.
And one way to avoid doing
that is to create a cache.
So here I have a cache just
storing the previous hypotenuse
that I calculated.
And I also store the
values of A and B
that were passed
to the function.
And then now when I call
the hypotenuse function,
I can first check if A is
equal to the cached value of A
and if B is equal to
the cached value of B.
And if both of
those are true, then
I already computed
the hypotenuse before.
And then I can just
return cached of h.
But if it's not in my cache, now
I need to actually compute it.
So I need to call the
square root function.
And then I store the
result into cached h.
And I also store A
and B into cached A
and cached B respectively.
And then finally, I
returned cached h.
So this example isn't
actually very realistic,
because my cache
is only a size one.
And it's very
unlikely, in a program,
you're going to repeatedly
call some function
with the same input arguments.
But you can actually
make a larger cache.
You can make a
cache of size 1,000,
storing the 1,000 most recently
computer hypotenuse values.
And then now when you call
the hypotenuse function,
you can just check if
it's in your cache.
Checking the larger
cache is going
to be more expensive,
because there are more values
to look at.
But they can still
save you time overall.
And hardware also
does caching for you,
as we'll talk about
later on in the semester.
But the point of
this optimization
is that you can also
do caching yourself.
You can do it in software.
You don't have to let
hardware do it for you.
And turns out for this
particular program here,
actually, it is about 30%
faster if you do hit the cache
about 2/3 of the time.
So it does actually
save you time
if you do repeatedly compute
the same values over and over
again.
So that's caching.
Any questions?
OK, so the next optimization
we'll look at is sparsity.
The idea of exploiting
sparsity, in an input,
is to avoid storage
and computing
on zero elements of that input.
And the fastest way
to compute on zero
is to just not compute
on them at all,
because we know that
any value plus zero
is just that original value.
And any value times
zero is just zero.
So why waste a computation
doing that when
you already know the result?
So let's look at an example.
This is matrix-vector
multiplication.
So we want to multiply a n by
n matrix by a n by one vector.
We can do dense
matrix-vector multiplication
by just doing a dot product
of each row in the matrix
with the column vector.
And then that will give
us the output vector.
But if you do dense
matrix-vector multiplication,
that's going to perform
n squared or 36,
in this example,
scalar multiplies.
But it turns out, only 14 of
these entries in this matrix
are zero or are non-zero.
So you just wasted work doing
the multiplication on the zero
elements, because you know that
zero times any other element
is just zero.
So a better way to do
this, is instead of
doing the multiplication
for every element,
you first check if one
of the arguments is zero.
And if it is zero,
then you don't
have to actually do
the multiplication.
But this is still kind of
slow, because you still
have to do a check for
every entry in your matrix,
even though many of
the entries are zero.
So it's actually a pretty
cool data structure
that won't actually
store these zero entries.
And this will speed up your
matrix-vector multiplication
if your matrix is sparse enough.
So let me describe how
this data structure works.
It's called compressed
sparse row or CSR.
There is an analogous
representation
called compressed
sparse column or CSC.
But today, I'm just
going to talk about CSR.
So we have three arrays.
First, we have the rows array.
The length of the rows array
is just equal to the number
of rows in a matrix plus one.
And then each entry
in the rows array
just stores an offset
into the columns array
or the cols array.
And inside the cols
array, I'm storing
the indices of the non-zero
entries in each of the rows.
So if we take row
one, for example,
we have rows of one
is equal to two.
That means I start looking
at the second entry
in the cols array.
And then now I have the
indices of the non-zero columns
in the first row.
So it's just one,
two, four, and five.
These are the indices
for the non-zero entries.
And then I have another
array called vals.
The length of this array is
the same as the cols array.
And then this array just
stores the actual value
in these indices here.
So the vals array
for row one is going
to store four, one, five,
and nine, because these
are the non-zero entries
in the first row.
Right, so the rows array
just serves as an index
into this cols array.
So you can basically
get the starting index
in this cols array
for any row just
by looking at the entry stored
at the corresponding location
in the rows array.
So for example, row two
starts at location six.
So it starts here.
And you have indices
three and five,
which are the non-zero indices.
So does anyone
know how to compute
the length, the number
of non-zeros in a row
by looking at the rows array?
Yes, yes?
AUDIENCE: You go
to the rows array
and just drag the [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
number of elements that are
[INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so to
get the length of a row,
you just take the difference
between that row's offset
and the next row's offset.
So we can see that the length
of the first row is four,
because it's offset is two.
And the offset for
row two is six.
So you just take the difference
between those two entries.
We have an additional
entry here.
So we have the sixth
row here, because we
want to be able to compute
the length of the last row
without overflowing
in our array.
So we just created an additional
entry in the rows array
for that.
So turns out that this
representation will save you
space if your matrix is sparse.
So the storage required
by the CSR format
is order n plus nnz, where
nnz is the number of non-zeros
in your matrix.
And the reason why
you have n plus nnz,
well, you have two arrays
here, cols and vals,
whose length is equal to
the number of non-zeros
in the matrix.
And then you also
have this rows array,
whose length is n plus one.
So that's why we
have n plus nnz.
And if the number of non-zeros
is much less than n squared,
then this is going to be
significantly more compact
than the dense matrix
representation.
However, this isn't always
going to be the most
compact representation.
Does anyone see why?
Why might the dense
representation
sometimes take less space?
Yeah?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Less
space or more space?
JULIAN SHUN: Why might the dense
representation sometimes take
less space?
AUDIENCE: I mean, if
you have not many zeros,
then you can figure it out n
squared plus something else
with the sparse created.
JULIAN SHUN: Right.
So if you have a
relatively dense matrix,
then it might take more
space than storing it.
It might take more space
in the CSR representation,
because you have
these two arrays.
So if you take the extreme
case where all of the entries
are non-zeros, then
both of these arrays
are going to be of
length and squares.
So you already have
2n squared there.
And then you also need
this rows array, which
is of length and plus one.
OK, so now I gave you this
more compact representation
for storing the matrix.
So how do we actually do stuff
with this representation?
So turns out that
you can still do
matrix-vector
multiplication using
this compressed
sparse row format.
And here's the
code for doing it.
So we have this
struct here, which
is the CSR representation.
We have the rows array, the cols
array, and then the vals array.
And then we also have the number
of rows, n, and the number
of non-zeros, nnz.
And then now what we do,
we call this SPMV or sparse
matrix-vector multiply.
We pass in our CSR
representation,
which is A, and then the
input array, which is x.
And then we store the
result in an output array y.
So first, we loop
through all the rows.
And then we set y
of i to be zero.
This is just initialization.
And then for each
of my rows, I'm
going to look at
the column indices
for the non-zero elements.
And I can do that by starting
at k equals to rows of i
and going up to
rows of i plus one.
And then for each
one of these entries,
I just look up the
index, the column index
for the non-zero element.
And I can do that with cols
of k, so let that be j.
And then now I know which
elements to multiply.
I multiply vals of k by x of j.
And then now I just
add that to y of i.
And then after I finish with
all of these multiplications
and additions, this will
give me the same result
as if I did the dense
matrix-vector multiplication.
So this is actually a
pretty cool program.
So I encourage you to look
at this program offline,
to convince yourself
that it's actually
computing the same thing
as the dense matrix-vector
multiplication version.
So I'm not going to approve
this during lecture today.
But you can feel free to
ask me or any of your TAs
after class, if you have
questions about this.
And the number of
scalar multiplication
that you have to
do using this code
is just going to be nnz,
because you're just operating
on the non-zero elements.
You don't have to touch
all of the zero elements.
And in contrast, the dense
matrix-vector multiply
algorithm would take n
squared multiplication.
So this can be significantly
faster for a sparse matrices.
So turns out that you can
also use a similar structure
to store a sparse static graph.
So I assume many of
you have seen graphs
in your previous courses.
See, here's what the
sparse graph representation
looks like.
So again, we have these arrays.
We have these two arrays.
We have offsets and edges.
The offsets array is
analogous to the rows array.
And the edges array is
analogous to the columns array
for the CSR representation.
And then in this offsets
array, we store for each vertex
where its neighbor's
start in this edges array.
And then in the
edges array, we just
write the indices of
its neighbor's there.
So let's take vertex
one, for example.
The offset of vertex one is two.
So we know that its
outgoing neighbor
start at position two
in this edges array.
And then we see that vertex one
has outgoing edges to vertices
two, three, and four.
And we see in the edges array
two, three, four listed there.
And you can also get the
degree of each vertex, which
is analogous to the
length of each row,
by taking the difference
between consecutive offsets.
So here we see that the
degree of vertex one
is three, because
its offset is two.
And the offset of
vertex two is five.
And it turns out that
using this representation,
you can run many
classic graph algorithms
such as breadth-first
search and PageRank
quite efficiently, especially
when the graph is sparse.
So this would be
much more efficient
than using a dense matrix
to represent the graph
and running these algorithms.
You can also store
weights on the edges.
And one way to do that is to
just create an additional array
called weights, whose length
is equal to the number of edges
in the graph.
And then you just store
the weights in that array.
And this is analogous to
the values array in the CSR
representation.
But there's actually a more
efficient way to store this,
if you always need to
access the weight whenever
you access an edge.
And the way to do this is
to interleave the weights
with the edges, so to store the
weight for a particular edge
right next to that edge,
and create an array of twice
number of edges in the graph.
And the reason why
this is more efficient
is, because it gives you
improved cache locality.
And we'll talk much more
about cache locality
later on in this course.
But the high-level idea is, that
whenever you access an edge,
the weight for
that edge will also
likely to be on the
same cache line.
So you don't need
to go to main memory
to access the weight
of that edge again.
And later on in
the semester we'll
actually have a whole lecture
on doing optimizations
for graph algorithms.
And today, I'm just going to
talk about one representation
of graphs.
But we'll talk much more
about this later on.
Any questions?
OK, so that's it for the
data structure optimizations.
We still have three
more categories
of optimizations to go over.
So it's a pretty fun lecture.
We get to learn about many
cool tricks for reducing
the work of your program.
So in the next class
of optimizations
we'll look at is logic, so
first thing is constant folding
and propagation.
The idea of constant
folding and propagation
is to evaluate
constant expressions
and substitute the result
into further expressions, all
at compilation times.
You don't have to
do it at runtime.
So again, let's
look at an example.
So here we have this
function called orrery.
Does anyone know
what orrery means?
You can look it up on Google.
[LAUGHING]
OK, so an orrery is a
model of a solar system.
So here we're constructing
a digital orrery.
And in an orrery we
have these whole bunch
of different constants.
We have the radius, the
diameter, the circumference,
cross area, surface area,
and also the volume.
But if you look
at this code, you
can notice that actually
all of these constants
can be defined in compile
time once we fix the radius.
So here we set the radius
to be this constant here,
six million, 371,000.
I don't know where that
constant comes from, by the way.
But Charles made these
slides, so he probably does.
CHARLES: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Sorry?
CHARLES: Radius of the Earth.
JULIAN SHUN: OK,
radius of the Earth.
Now, the diameter is
just twice this radius.
The circumference is just
pi times the diameter.
Cross area is pi times
the radius squared.
Surface area is circumference
times the diameter.
And finally, volume is four
times pi times the radius cube
divided by three.
So you can actually evaluate
all of these two constants
at compile time.
So with a sufficiently
high level of optimization,
the compiler will actually
evaluate all of these things
at compile time.
And that's the idea of constant
folding and propagation.
It's a good idea to know about
this, even though the compiler
is pretty good at doing
this, because sometimes
the compiler won't do it.
And in those cases,
you can do it yourself.
And you can also figure
out whether the compiler
is actually doing it when you
look at the assembly code.
OK, so the next optimization
is common subexpression
elimination.
And the idea here is to avoid
computing the same expression
multiple times by evaluating
the expression once and storing
the result for later use.
So let's look at this
simple four-line program.
We have a equal to b plus c.
The we set b equal to a minus d.
Then we set c equal to b plus c.
And finally, we set
d equal to a minus d.
So notice her that the
second and the fourth lines
are computing the
same expression.
They're both
computing a minus d.
And they evaluate
to the same thing.
So the idea of common
subexpression elimination
would be to just substitute the
result of the first evaluation
into the place where you
need it in future line.
So here, we still evaluate
the first line for a minus d.
But now in the second
time we need a minus d.
We just set the value to b.
So now d is equal to b
instead of a minus d.
So in this example, the
first and the third line,
the right hand side of those
lines actually look the same.
They're both b plus c.
Does anyone see why you
can't do common subexpression
elimination here?
AUDIENCE: b minus
changes the second line.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so you
can't do common subexpression
for the first and the third
lines, because the value of b
changes in between.
So the value of b changes
on the second line.
So on the third line
when you do b plus c,
it's not actually
computing the same thing
as the first
evaluation of b plus c.
So again, the
compiler is usually
smart enough to figure
this optimization out.
So it will do this optimization
for you in your code.
But again, it doesn't
always do it for you.
So it's a good idea to know
about this optimization
so that you can do this
optimization by hand when
the compiler doesn't
do it for you.
Questions so far?
OK, so next, let's look
at algebraic identities.
The idea of exploiting
algebraic identities
is to replace more expensive
algebraic expressions
with equivalent expressions
that are cheaper to evaluate.
So let's look at an example.
Let's say we have a
whole bunch of balls.
And we want to detect
whether two balls collide
with each other.
Say, ball has a x-coordinate,
a y-coordinate, a z-coordinate,
as well as a radius.
And the collision
test works as follows.
We set d equal to
the square root
of the sum of the squares of
the differences between each
of the three coordinates
of the two balls.
So here, we're taking the
square of b1's x-coordinate
minus b2's
x-coordinate, and then
adding the square
of b1's y-coordinate
minus b2's y-coordinate,
and finally,
adding the square
of b1 z-coordinate
minus b2's z-coordinate.
And then we take the
square root of all of that.
And then if the
result is less than
or equal to the sum of
the two radii of the ball,
then that means
there is a collision,
and otherwise, that means
there's not a collision.
But it turns out that
the square root operator,
as I mentioned before, is
relatively expensive compared
to doing multiplications and
additions and subtractions
on modern machines.
So how can we do this without
using the square root operator?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You add the two radii,
and the distance is more than
the distance
between the centers,
then you know that
they must be overlying.
JULIAN SHUN: Right, so that's
actually a good fast path
check.
I don't think it
necessarily always gives you
the right answer.
Is there another?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You can square
the ignition of the radii
and compare that
instead of taking
the square root of [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Right,
right, so the answer
is, that you can actually
take the square of both sides.
So now you don't have to
take the square root anymore.
So we're going to
use the identity that
says, that if the
square root of u
is less than or equal to v
exactly when u is less than
or equal to v squared.
So we're just going to take
the square of both sides.
And here's the modified code.
So now I don't have this square
root anymore on the right hand
side when I compute d squared.
But instead, I square
the sum of the two radii.
So this will give
you the same answer.
However, you do have to be
careful with floating point
operations, because
they don't work exactly
in the same way as real numbers.
So some numbers might run into
overflow issues or rounding
issues.
So you do have to
be careful if you're
using algebraic identities and
floating point computations.
But the high-level
idea is that you
can use equivalent algebraic
expressions to reduce
the work of your program.
And we'll come back
to this example
late on in this
lecture when we talk
about some other optimizations,
such as the fast path
optimization, as one of
the students pointed out.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why do
you square the sum
of these squares [INAUDIBLE]?
JULIAN SHUN: Which?
Are you talking about--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JULIAN SHUN: --this line?
So before we were comparing d.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
yeah, OK, is that clear?
OK.
OK, so the next optimization
is short-circuiting.
The idea here is,
that when we're
performing a series of
tests, we can actually
stop evaluating
this series of tests
as soon as we know what the
answer is So here's an example.
Let's say we have an
array, a, containing
all non-negative integers.
And we want to check if
the sum of the values
in a exceed some limit.
So the simple way to
do this is, you just
sum up all of the values of
the array using a for loop.
And then at the end, you
check if the total sum
is greater than the limit.
So using this
approach, you always
have to look at all the
elements in the array.
But there's actually a
better way to do this.
And the idea here
is, that once you
know the partial sum exceeds
the limit that you're
testing against, then
you can just return true,
because at that point you know
that the sum of the elements
in the array will
exceed the limit,
because all of the elements
in the array are non-negative.
And then if you get all the way
to the end of this for loop,
that means you didn't
exceed this limit.
And you can just return false.
So this second program
here will usually
be faster, if most
of the time you
exceed the limit
pretty early on when
you loop through the array.
But if you actually end up
looking at most of the elements
anyways, or even looking
at all the elements,
this second program
will actually
be a little bit slower, because
you have this additional check
inside this for loop that has
to be done for every iteration.
So when you apply
this optimization,
you should be aware of
whether this will actually
be faster or slower, based
on the frequency of when
you can short-circuit the test.
Questions?
OK, and I want to point out
that there are short-circuiting
logical operators.
So if you do double
ampersand, that's
short-circuiting
logical and operator.
So if it evaluates the
left side to be false,
it means that the whole
thing has to be false.
So it's not even going to
evaluate the right side.
And then the double
vertical bar is going
to be a short-circuiting or.
So if it knows that
the left side is true,
it knows the whole thing has
to be true, because or just
requires one of the
two sides to be true.
And it's going to short circuit.
In contrast, if you just
have a single ampersand
or a single vertical
bar, these are not
short-circuiting operators.
They're going to evaluate
both sides of the argument.
The single ampersand
and single vertical bar
turn out to be
pretty useful when
you're doing bit manipulation.
And we'll be talking
about these operators
more on Thursday's lecture.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if your
program going to send false,
if it were to call the
function and that function
was on the right hand
side of an ampersand,
would it mean that
would never get called,
even though-- and
you possibly now
find out that, the right
hand side would crash simply
because the left
hand side was false?
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, if you
use a double ampersand,
then that would be true.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
check [INAUDIBLE]
that would cause the
cycle of left hand,
so that the right hand
doesn't get [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
I guess one example is, if
you might possibly index
an array out of
balance, you can first
check whether you would exceed
the limit or be out of bounds.
And if so, then you don't
actually do the index.
OK, a related idea is
to order tests, suss
out the tests that are more
often successful or earlier.
And the ones that are
less frequently successful
are later in the
order, because you
want to take advantage
of short-circuiting.
And similarly, inexpensive tests
should precede expensive tests,
because if you do the
inexpensive tests and your test
short-circuit,
then you don't have
to do the more expensive tests.
So here's an example.
Here, we're checking whether
a character is whitespace.
So character's
whitespace, if it's
equal to the carriage
return character,
if it's equal to
the tab character,
space, or if it's
equal to the newline character.
So which one of
these tests do you
think should go
at the beginning?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Probably the space.
JULIAN SHUN: Why is that?
AUDIENCE: Oh, I
mean [INAUDIBLE]..
Well, maybe the
newline [INAUDIBLE]..
Either of those
could be [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
yeah, so it turns out
that the space and
the newline characters
appear more frequently
than the carriage return.
And the tab and the space
is the most frequent,
because you have a
lot of spaces in text.
So here I've reordered the test,
so that the check for space
is first.
And then now if you have a
character, that's a space.
You can just short circuit
this test and return true.
Next, the newline character,
I have it as a second test,
because these are
also pretty frequent.
You have a newline for
every new line in your text.
And then less frequent
is the tab character,
and finally, the carriage
return for character
isn't that frequently
used nowadays.
So now with this ordering,
the most frequently successful
tests are going to appear first.
Notice that this only
actually saves you
work if the character is
a whitespace character.
It it's not a
whitespace character,
than you're going to end up
evaluating all of these tests
anyways.
OK, so now let's go back to this
example of detecting collision
of balls.
So we're going to look at the
idea of creating a fast path.
And the idea of
creating a fast path
is, that there might
possibly be a check that
will enable you to
exit the program early,
because you already
know what the result is.
And one fast path check
for this particular program
here is, you can check whether
the bounding boxes of the two
balls intersect.
If you know the bounding
boxes of the two balls
don't intersect, then you know
that the balls cannot collide.
If the bounding boxes of
the two balls do intersect,
well, then you have to do
the more expensive test,
because that doesn't
necessarily mean
that the balls will collide.
So here's what the fast
path test looks like.
We're first going to check
whether the bounding boxes
intersect.
And we can do this by
looking at the absolute value
of the difference on
each of the coordinates
and checking if that's greater
than the sum of the two radii.
And if so, that means that
for that particular coordinate
the bounding boxes
cannot intersect.
And therefore, the
balls cannot collide.
And then we can return
false of any one
of these tests returned true.
And otherwise, we'll do
the more expensive test
of comparing d square to the
square of the sum of the two
radii.
And the reason why
this is a fast path
is, because this test
here is actually cheaper
to evaluate than
this test below.
Here, we're just doing
subtractions, additions,
and comparisons.
And below we're using the
square operator, which
requires a multiplication.
And multiplications are usually
more expensive than additions
on modern machines.
So ideally, if we don't need
to do the multiplication,
we can avoid it by going
through our fast path.
So for this example,
it probably isn't
worth it to do the fast
path check since it's
such a small program.
But in practice there are
many applications and graphics
that benefit greatly from
doing fast path checks.
And the fast path
check will greatly
improve the performance of
these graphics programs.
There's actually
another optimization
that we can do here.
I talked about this optimization
couple of slides ago.
Does anyone see it?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You can factor
out the sum of the radii
for [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Right.
So we can apply common
subexpression elimination here,
because we're computing the sum
of the two radii four times.
We can actually just compute it
once, store it in a variable,
and then use it for the
subsequent three calls.
And then similarly,
when we're taking
the difference between
each of the coordinates,
we're also doing it twice.
So again, we can store
that in a variable
and then just use the
result in the second time.
Any questions?
OK, so the next idea is
to combine tests together.
So here, we're going to
replace a sequence of tests
with just one test
or switch statement.
So here's an implementation
of a full adder.
So a full adder is
a hardware device
that takes us input three bits.
And then it returns the carry
bit and the sum bit as output.
So here's a table that specifies
for every possible input
to the full adder of what
the output should be.
And there are eight possible
inputs to the full adder,
because it takes three bits.
And there are eight
possibilities there.
And this program here is going
to check all the possibilities.
It's first going to check
if a is equal to zero.
If so, it checks if
b is equal to zero.
c is equal to zero.
And if that's true, it returns
zero and zero for the two bits.
And otherwise, it returns
one and zero and so on.
So this is basically
a whole bunch
of if else statements
nested together.
Does anyone think this is a
good way to write the program?
Who thinks this is a bad
way to write the program?
OK, so most of you think it's
a bad way to write the program.
And hopefully, I can
convince the rest of you
who didn't raise your hand.
So here's a better way
to write this program.
So we're going to replace
these multiple if else clauses
with a single switch statement.
And what we're going
to do is, we're going
to create this test variable.
That is a three-bit variable.
So we're going to
place the c bit
in the least significant digit.
The b bit, we're going
to shift it over by one,
so in the second least
significant digit,
and then the a bit in the
third least significant digit.
And now the value of
this test variable
is going to range
from zero to seven.
And then for each
possibility, we
can just specify what the sum
and the carry bits should be.
And this requires just a single
switch statement, instead of
a whole bunch of
if else clauses.
There's actually an even
better way to do this,
for this example, which
is to use table lookups.
You just precompute all these
answers, store it in a table,
and then just look
it up at runtime.
But the idea here is that you
can combine multiple tests
in a single test.
And this not only makes
your code cleaner,
but it can also improve the
performance of your program,
because you're not
doing so many checks.
And you won't have as
many branch misses.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Would coming up
with logic gates for this
be better or no?
JULIAN SHUN: Maybe.
Yeah, I mean, I encourage you
to see if you can write a faster
program for this.
All right, so we're
done with two categories
of optimizations.
We still have two more to go.
The third category is
going to be about loops.
So if we didn't have any
loops in our programs,
well, there wouldn't be
many interesting programs
to optimize, because
most of our programs
wouldn't be very long running.
But with loops we can
actually optimize these loops
and then realize the benefits
of performance engineering.
The first loop optimization I
want to talk about is hoisting.
The goal of hoisting, which is
also called loop-invariant code
motion, is to avoid recomputing
a loop-invariant code
each time through
the body of a loop.
So if you have a for loop
where in each iteration
are computing the
same thing, well, you
can actually save work by
just computing it once.
So in this example
here, I'm looping
over an array of length N.
And them I'm setting Y of i
equal to X of i times the
exponential of the square root
of pi over two.
But this exponential
square root of pi over two
is actually the same
in every iteration.
So I don't actually have
to compute that every time.
So here's a version of the
code that does hoisting.
I just move this expression
outside of the for loop
and stored it in
a variable factor.
And then now inside
the for loop,
I just have to
multiply by factor.
I already computed what
this expression is.
And this can save running
time, because computing
the exponential, the
square root of pi over two,
is actually
relatively expensive.
So turns out that for
this example, you know,
the compiler can
probably figure it out
and do this hoisting for you.
But in some cases,
the compiler might not
be able to figure
it out, especially
if these functions here might
change throughout the program.
So it's a good idea to know
what this optimization is,
so you can apply it in your code
when the compiler doesn't do it
for you.
OK, sentinels, so sentinels
are special dummy values
placed in a data structure to
simplify the logic of handling
boundary conditions, and in
particular the handling of loop
exit tests.
So here, I, again, have this
program that checks whether--
so I have this
program that checks
whether the sum of the
elements in sum array A
will overflow if I added all
of the elements together.
And here, I've specified
that all of the elements of A
are non-negative.
So how I do this is,
in every iteration
I'm going to increment
some by A of i.
And then I'll check if the
resulting sum is less than A
of i.
Does anyone see why this will
detect if I had an overflow?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: We're a
closed algorithm.
It's not taking any values.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so
if the thing I added in
causes an overflow, then the
result is going to wrap around.
And it's going to be less
than the thing I added in.
So this is why the
check here, that
checks whether the sum
is less than negative i,
will detect an overflow.
OK, so I'm going to do this
check in every iteration.
If it's true, I'll
just return true.
And otherwise, I get to
the end of this for loop
where I just return false.
But here on every iteration,
I'm doing two checks.
I'm first checking
whether I should
exit the body of this loop.
And then secondly, I'm checking
whether the sum is less than A
of i.
It turns out that I can
actually modify this program,
so that I only need
to do one check
in every iteration of the loop.
So here's a modified
version of this program.
So here, I'm going
to assume that I
have two additional
entries in my array A.
So these are A of n
and A of n minus one.
So I assume I can
use these locations.
And I'm going to set A of n
to be the largest possible
64-bit integer, or INT64 MAX.
And I'm going to set A
of n plus one to be one.
And then now I'm going to
initialize my loop variable
i to be zero.
And then I'm going to set the
sum equal to the first element
in A or A of zero.
And then now I
have this loop that
checks whether the sum is
greater than or equal to A
of i.
And if so, I'm going to add
A of i plus one to the sum.
And then I also increment i.
OK, and this code here
does the same thing
as a thing on the left,
because the only way
I'm going to exit this while
loop is, if I overflow.
And I'll overflow if A of
i becomes greater than sum,
or if the sum
becomes less than A
of i, which is what I had
in my original program.
And then otherwise, I'm going
to just increment sum by A of i.
And then this code here is
going to eventually overflow,
because if the
elements in my array A
don't cause the
program to overflow,
I'm going to get to A of n.
And A of n is a
very large integer.
And if I add that
to what I have,
it's going to cause the
program to overflow.
And at that point,
I'm going to exit this
for loop or this while loop.
And then after I exit this loop,
I can check why I overflowed.
If I overflowed because
of sum element of A,
then the loop index i is
going to be less than n,
and I return true.
But if I overflowed because
I added in this huge integer,
well, than i is going
to be equal to n.
And then I know that
the elements of A
didn't caused me to overflow,
the A of n value here did.
So then I just return false.
So does this makes sense?
So here in each
iteration, I only
have to do one check
instead of two checks,
as in my original code.
I only have to check whether
the sum is greater than
or equal to A of i.
Does anyone know why I set A
of n plus one equal to one?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If everything else
in the array was zero, then
you still wouldn't
have overflowed.
If you had been at 64
max, it would overflow.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so good.
So the answer is, because
if all of my elements
were zero in my original
array, that even
though I add in
this huge integer,
it's still not
going to overflow.
But now when I get
to A of n plus one,
I'm going to add one to it.
And then that will cause
the sum to overflow.
And then I can exit there.
So this is a deal with
the boundary condition
when all the entries
in my array are zero.
OK, so next, loop
unrolling, so loop unrolling
attempts to save
work by combining
several consecutive
iterations of a loop
into a single iteration.
Thereby, reducing
the total number
of iterations of the
loop and consequently
the number of times that the
instructions that control
the loop have to be executed.
So there are two types
of loop unrolling.
There's full loop
unrolling, where
I unroll all of the
iterations of the for loop,
and I just get rid of the
control-flow logic entirely.
Then there's partial loop
unrolling, where I only
unroll some of the iterations
but not all of the iterations.
So I still have some
control-flow code in my loop.
So let's first look at
full loop unrolling.
So here, I have a
simple program that
just loops for 10 iterations.
The fully unrolled loop
just looks like the code
on the right hand side.
I just wrote out all
of the lines of code
that I have to do in
straight-line code,
instead of using a for loop.
And now I don't need to
check on every iteration,
whether I need to
exit the for loop.
So this is for loop unrolling.
This is actually
not very common,
because most of
your loops are going
to be much larger than 10.
And oftentimes, many
of your loop bounds
are not going to be
determined at compile time.
They're determined at runtime.
So the compiler can't fully
unroll that loop for you.
For small loops like
this, the compiler
will probably unroll
the loop for you.
But for larger
loops, it actually
doesn't benefit to
unroll the loop fully,
because you're going to
have a lot of instructions.
And that's going to pollute
your instruction cache.
So the more common
form of loop unrolling
is partial loop unrolling.
And here, in this
example here, I've
unrolled the loop
by a factor of four.
So I reduce the number of
iterations of my for loop
by a factor of four.
And then inside the
body of each iteration
I have four instructions.
And then notice, I
also changed the logic
in the control-flow
of my for loops.
So now I'm incrementing
the variable j
by four instead of just by one.
And then since n
might not necessarily
be divisible by four, I have
to deal with the remaining
elements.
And this is what the second
for loop is doing here.
It's just dealing with
the remaining elements.
And this is the more common
form of loop unrolling.
So the first benefit
of doing this
is, that you have fewer
checks to the exit condition
for the loop,
because you only have
to do this check every
four iterations instead
of every iteration.
But the second and
much bigger benefit
is, that it allows more
compiler optimizations,
because it increases the
size of the loop body.
And it gives the
compiler more freedom
to play around with code
and to find ways to optimize
the performance of that code.
So that's usually
the bigger benefit.
If you unroll the
loop by too much,
that actually isn't very
good, because now you're
going to be pleading
your instruction cache.
And every time you
fetch an instruction,
it's likely going to be a miss
in your instruction cache.
And that's going to decrease
the performance of your program.
And furthermore, if your loop
body is already very big,
you don't really get
additional improvements
from having the compiler
do more optimizations,
because it already has
enough code to work with.
So giving it more code doesn't
actually give you much there.
OK, so I just said this.
The benefits of loop unrolling
a lower number of instructions
and loop control code.
And then it also enables
more compiler optimizations.
And the second benefit here is
usually the much more important
benefit.
And we'll talk more about
compiler optimizations
in a couple of lectures.
OK, any questions?
OK, so the next
optimization is loop fusion.
This is also called jamming.
And the idea here is to
combine multiple loops
over the same index
range into a single loop,
thereby saving the
overhead of loop control.
So here, I have two loops.
They're both looping from i
equal zero, all the way up
to n minus one.
The first loop, I'm computing
the minimum of A of i
and B of i and storing
the result in C of i.
The second loop, I'm computing
the maximum of A of i
and B of i and storing
the result in D of i.
So since these are going
over the same index rang,
I can fused together
the two loops,
giving me a single loop that
does both of these lines here.
And this reduces the overhead
of loop control code,
because now instead of doing
this exit condition check two n
times, I only have
to do it n times.
This also gives you
better cache locality.
Again, we'll talk more
about cache locality
in a future lecture.
But at a high
level here, what it
gives you is, that once you load
A of i and B of i into cache,
when you compute
C of i, it's also
going to be in cache
when you compute D of i.
Whereas, in the original
code, when you compute D of i,
it's very likely that
A of i and B of i
are going to be kicked
out of cache already,
even though you brought it
in when you computed C of i.
For this example
here, again, there's
another optimization you
can do, common subexpression
elimination, since you're
computing this expression
A of i is less than or
equal to B of i twice.
OK, next, let's look at
eliminating wasted iterations.
The idea of eliminating
wasted iterations
is to modify the
loop bounds to avoid
executing loop iterations over
essentially empty loop bodies.
So here, I have some code
to transpose, a matrix.
So I go from i equal
zero to n minus one,
from j equals zero
to n minus one.
And then I check if
i is greater than j.
And if so, I'll swap the entries
in A of i, j and A of j, i.
The reason why I
have this check here
is, because I don't want
to do the swap twice.
Otherwise, I'll just end up with
the same matrix I had before.
So I only have to do the swap
when i is greater than j.
One disadvantage of this
code here is, I still
have to loop for n
squared iterations,
even though only about
half of the iterations
are actually doing useful
work, because about half
of the iterations are going
to fail this check here,
that checks whether
i is greater than j.
So here's a modified version of
the program, where I basically
eliminate these
wasted iterations.
So now I'm going to loop from
i equals one to n minus one,
and then from j equals zero
all the way up to i minus one.
So now instead of going
up to n minus one,
I'm going just up
to i minus one.
And that basically
puts this check,
whether i is greater than j,
into the loop control code.
And that saves me the
extra wasted iterations.
OK, so that's the last
optimization on loops.
Are there any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Isn't the checks
still have [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN SHUN: So the check is--
so you still have to do the
check in the loop control code.
But here, you also had to do it.
And now you just don't
have to do it again
inside the body of the loop.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In some
cases, where it
might be more complex
to do it, is it
also [INAUDIBLE]
before you optimize it,
but it's still going to be
fast enough [INAUDIBLE]..
Like in the first example,
even though the loop is empty,
most of the time you'll be
able to process [INAUDIBLE]
run the instructions.
JULIAN SHUN: Yes,
so most of these
are going to be branch hits.
So it's still going
to be pretty fast.
But it's going to be
even faster if you just
don't do that check at all.
So I mean, basically you
should just text it out
in your code to see
whether it will give you
a runtime improvement.
OK, so last category of
optimizations is functions.
So first, the idea
of inlining is
to avoid the overhead
of a function call
by replacing a call to
the function with the body
of the function itself.
So here, I have a
piece of code that's
computing the sum of squares
of elements in an array A.
And so I have this for
loop that in each iteration
is calling this square function.
And the square function
is defined above here.
It just does x times x
for input argument x.
But it turns out that there
is actually some overhead
to doing a function call.
And the idea here is
to just put the body
of the function inside the
function that's calling it.
So instead of calling
the square function,
I'm just going to
create a variable temp.
And then I set sum equal to
sum plus temp times temp.
So now I don't have to do
the additional function call.
You don't actually have
to do this manually.
So if you declare your
function to be static inline,
then the compiler
is going to try
to inline this function
for you by placing
the body of the function inside
the code that's calling it.
And nowadays, the compiler
is pretty good at doing this.
So even if you don't
declare static inline,
the compiler will probably
still inline this code for you.
But just to make sure, if you
want to inline a function,
you should declare
it as static inline.
And you might ask, why can't
you just use a macro to do this?
But it turns out, that inline
functions nowadays are just
as efficient as macros.
But they're better structured,
because they evaluate
all of their arguments.
Whereas, macros just do
a textual substitution.
So if you have an
argument that's
very expensive to
evaluate, the macro
might actually paste that
expression multiple times
in your code.
And if the compiler
isn't good enough
to do common
subexpression elimination,
then you've just
wasted a lot of work.
OK, so there's one
more optimization--
or there's two
more optimizations
that I'm not going to
have time to talk about.
But I'm going to post these
slides on Learning Modules,
so please take a look at them,
tail-recursion elimination
and coarsening recursion.
So here are a list
of most of the roles
that we looked at today.
There are two of the
function optimizations
I didn't get to talk
about, please take
a look at that offline,
and ask your TAs if you
have any questions.
And some closing
advice is, you should
avoid premature optimizations.
So all of the things
I've talked about today
improve the performance
of your program.
But you first need to make sure
that your program is correct.
If you have a program that
doesn't do the right thing,
then it doesn't really
benefit you to make it faster.
And to preserve correctness, you
should do regression testing,
so develop a suite
of tests to check
the correctness of
your program every time
you change the program.
And as I said before,
reducing the work of a program
doesn't necessarily
decrease its running time.
But it's a good heuristic.
And finally, the
compiler automates
many low-level optimizations.
And you can look at
the assembly code
to see whether the
compiler did something.